yippie ki movie lovers it's Chan here
and today I want to talk about some of
the key moments in the third and final
Maze Runner movie the death cure as well
as how they affected its ending and I'll
also reveal some interesting details
connections and Easter eggs you might
have missed in the movie if this is your
first time on my channel I do regular
breakdowns of new movies so don't forget
to hit the subscribe button a
notification bell to get my videos as
soon as I post them plus later in the
video I'm also announcing the winner of
my latest giveaway quick warning I will
be discussing spoilers from Maze Runner
the death cure so take care if you've
not seen the movie yet let's start with
the final scene and work our way back to
earlier moments which connect to it
Thomas wakes up from his injuries to
find himself in the safe haven with
meanhow and the other surviving immunes
and there's an emotional moment for
Thomas when he finds a note inside the
necklace that Newt gave him in the
letter Newt tells his friends that the
thing that scares him the most about the
virus is losing his memory to it memory
has been an important theme throughout
the Maze Runner films with the first
movie showing the glade as having no
recollection of their lives before
entering the maze and note how in this
latest film Teresa wants to keep her
memories of Thomas despite over pages
offer to wipe them away after all as
Teresa says if we find a cure that's the
only way all of this was worth it okay
back to newsletter he goes on to say
that if he could do everything all over
again he would and he wouldn't change a
thing
and he hopes that Thomas will feel the
same years from now Newt endure stands
at Thomas has always been the key to
everyone's survival and he tells him
that the future is in Thomas's hands now
and that he'll have to find a way to do
what's right soon after when Thomas
takes the vaccine Teresa gave him out of
his pocket newts words turn out to be
literally true as Thomas does indeed
hold the secret to saving humanity in
his hands and then the moment that
showcases the trilogy's key theme of
memory this Vince's speech to the
survivors in a safe haven when he
reveals a large memorial stone to honor
those who didn't make it if you look
carefully you'll spot the names of
characters who died during the series
such as large from the first movie was
also
hidden in there are a few crew names
like where's not to Westfall who
directed all three movies this moment
also calls to mind the first Maze Runner
movie when the Gladers crossed out a
name on the maze wall whenever they lost
one of their group Thomas carved
Teresa's name into the memorial rock in
honor of her sacrifice to save him on
top of the burning wicked building
Teresa's death was poignant not only
because of her feelings for Thomas but
also because her sacrifice was in
keeping with her ultimate goal to find a
vaccine for the Fleur virus for the
whole of humanity not just a select few
that Janssen wanted to help although she
betrayed the immunes at the end of the
Scorch Trials it was only because she
believed in the idea that wicked was
good and she always thought the immunes
sacrifice would ultimately save the
human race from devastation
when Thomas asks her in the death cure
if she regretted what she'd done she
simply replies sometimes but I did what
I thought was right and I'd do it again
a sentiment which is later echoed in
newts letter to Thomas as Janssen said
to Teresa what I like about you is no
matter how bleak things get you never
give up and in the end she was the one
who made the breakthrough as she
understood that Brenda's recovery after
getting the serum from Thomas and the
Scorch Trials meant something different
was going on which is why in this film
she smuggled out Thomas's bloody bandage
and inspected it in the lab although she
found it difficult to see her friends
suffer in Teresa's mind it was
ultimately worthwhile for what she saw
as the greater good when she and Thomas
are on the roof of the wicked building
she's aware they're both in mortal
danger and understands that Thomas is
the key to humanity's survival so she
gives him the serum of his blood that
she was carrying and ensures that he
gets on the aircraft first with Teresa
and Ava Paige dead at the end of the
death cure and the right arm scientists
Mary killed at the end of the Scorch
Trials it's not entirely clear who will
have the expertise to replicate the
vaccine but I guess it's somewhere among
the survivors there may be another
scientist who can help
the other poignant death scene and the
death cure was of course when Thomas had
to kill Newt after the flare infection
finally turned Newt into a crank and he
stabbed Thomas in the chest it was
plenty of foreshadowing for newts
eventual transformation into a crank
throughout the movies for example during
Thomas's hallucination seen in the
Scorch Trials he saw a vision of Newt as
a crank and in the death cure just
before Thomas Newton frypan ventured
into the tunnel Newt said I don't want
to come across as too negative but if I
was a crank that's exactly where I'd be
and then the thing foreshadowing newts
death in this film is a jar containing
what appears to be a dead Newt which you
can see briefly in rebel leader
Lawrence's room
Brenda's lied to Thomas in the movie
that you can't save everyone is also a
bit of foreshadowing for when Thomas
stabs Newt however it has a double
meaning because by the end of the movie
we know that Thomas can't save everyone
as his blood is the basis for the
ultimate vaccine against the Fleur virus
there's also a nice parallel between
Newt giving his necklace to Thomas once
he realizes he's unlikely to survive and
Chuck who gave Thomas his wooden carving
as he died in the first Maze Runner film
and when Newt explained to Thomas that
wicked must have put him into the maze
so they could tell the difference
between immunes like you and people like
me it's a reference to newts backstory
in the books where Newt had a sister who
was an immune abducted by wicked in the
books wicked decided to take meat with
them as well to use him as a control
subject in their trials to see how
immunes performed compared to ordinary
people like him one new character we
meet in the death cure is Lawrence the
rebel leader galleys working for outside
the last city when we meet him for the
first time he has a curious interest in
roses despite the loss of his nose and
much of his face to the Fleur virus this
version of Lawrence is a clever
reference that book fans will recognize
as he's partially based on the Rose took
my nose crank that Thomas encountered in
the Scorch Trials book but who never
made it into the second Maze Runner
movie now did you enjoy the death cure
film and
you find the ending satisfying and if
you've read the original books how do
you think the movie series compares feel
free to share your thoughts in the
comments below if you enjoyed this
remember to hit that thumbs up button
share this video and also subscribe to
get more regular videos like this the
winner of my second Star Wars the last
Jedi giveaway is on the screen right now
and if that's you send me a private
message with your details to get your
prize check out more videos you might
like by tapping the screen right here
thanks for watching and see you next
time you became movie lovers